hello the internet i'm gav welcome to
this slightly different episode of the
slo-mo guys where i'm going to be
visualizing
why it's important to wear a mask in
public during a pandemic such as this
one
we're quite visual creatures as humans i
feel like
and when dealing with an invisible virus
it's often hard to get your head around
all the mechanics of how everything
works
so i'm going to be using two methods
today to help visualize the situation
one slow motion footage two i'm gonna
make it look
really gross using the rather simple
technique of
harshly backlighting my mouth and
filming what comes out of it with the
phantom
we should get some disgustingly clear
footage of
how many particles can leak out of
someone's face
it's not the same as schlieren you won't
necessarily see the airflow
and the change in density in the air but
if you do want to see a good video
involving schlieren make sure you check
out
joe hansen's video which i'll put in the
the card thing
up there then we're going to watch the
footage back with a special guest
okie dokie we're filming a thousand
frames a second in 4k with a 90 degree
shutter just to sharpen up some of the
motion blur
on the the speedy globs of gauze
i'm going to shine the backlight
straight into the lens
and basically block it with my head i'll
do a little demonstration for you on
this one
if i turn off these lights and turn on
this bright one
you can see that when i when i get in
the way it really highlights all the
particles
that's disgusting one okay so you won't
see the white
in the phantom shot just because the
ambient light of the walls
is not nearly bright enough to show up
on the phantom so it should be a nice
backlit
black background so now i'm going to
reposition this and do it on the phantom
i'll start with a cough
and then i'll do a just a bit of talking
maybe just count to five or something
okay let's do it okay i'm now framed for
the phantom the backlight
even though it's not for you is now
completely eclipsing the phantom lens so
here we go oh god
it feels strange just to just cough into
the air without covering it
okay we'll save that
all right rolling again i'm just going
to count to four
one two three four
just really showing off the dust in this
room i've just glanced the footage this
is actually quite interesting
i'm surprised it i'm surprised what i'm
seeing i'm now going to do a test with a
mask
i'm going to repeat the experiment do
the same again
okay
sorry if i seem distracted i'm looking
up at a monitor where i can frame myself
up
on the phantom the beard at the bottom
is not a good look
okay repeating the talking test
one two three four wow i'm not seeing
anything now
a bit more pepper
oh
oh no i can't stop
oh
it's so nasty
oh the string i've stringed my nose
how do i unsee something
okay so now i've got the footage i want
i've got some good comparisons between
wearing a mask and not wearing a mask
so why don't we watch the footage back
and have a little chat
with dr fauci hello hi there
nice to meet you dr fauci same here good
to be with you thank you for having me
my name's gavin i run a channel on
youtube that specializes in super slow
motion footage
and i've actually shot something for you
so we can watch it together if you've
got the clip ready
yes did you want us to play it now
yeah i think it'll be a good jumping off
point and then
if you have time i can ask you a few
more questions maybe all right
so this is footage i shot it's a
thousand frames a second which is
roughly
40 times slower than how it appeared in
real time
and i just counted from one to four
those are the numbers you can see at the
bottom of the screen
and i was blown away at the amount of
particles that came out of my mouth not
only from the spit
sort of the beginning of each word but
after i'm done
with the word particularly the word for
you can see
like a fine mist come out of my mouth
and that was actually really surprising
i could see that with
with the naked eye the particles that
are so light that they don't fall
and i wasn't even shouting that loud
that was like a medium volume
of talking there yeah i think what
you've just shown is a
is a you know graphically
uh beautiful uh demonstration
of the importance of wearing masks and
face coverings
because as the as the film shows now
you're saying the same thing one two
three four
right and very little is coming out from
the mask
so you know we say
and and and i think graphic
demonstrations like you've just shown
now
really solidify that one of the reasons
why it's so important
to wear a face covering is that we know
now that about 40 to 45 percent of the
people who are infected
don't have any symptoms and yet
they have virus in their nasal pharynx
and we know that a substantial
proportion of
infections are transmitted from someone
who doesn't have any symptoms so people
have an understandable but incorrect
interpretation
that the only time you transmit
infection is when you're coughing and
sneezing all over someone
what they don't appreciate is that if
you are speaking
even if you don't speak loudly and if
you are singing which is even worse
than just speaking you have these
particles that come out
that can stay in the air for a period of
time some of them drop to the ground
which is the reason why we say
keep six feet of distance but some of
them
are aerosolized and can hang around the
air for a period of time
for that reason it's so important to
wear face coverings particularly
when you think you're in a situation
where well um nobody's sneezing or
coughing doesn't matter
you proved it beautifully by just saying
one two three four
well thank you very much for your input
on that footage i'm glad it i'm glad i
was able to show something worthwhile
i do have some additional questions just
about covert in general if you have time
sure so my first question is with the
vaccine on the way
will a large number of people refusing
the vaccine
reduce the overall effectiveness of the
vaccine
absolutely and that's the reason why
when we conduct
these clinical trials you want to do it
in a scientifically
sound and ethically sound manner where
you
absolutely prove definitively
that a vaccine is safe and effective
which is really the case with
so many of the life-saving vaccines
that we've done similar types of tests
on because if you get
only a small proportion of
the the population vaccinated
the vax the virus still has the
capability of spreading around
to those people who are not vaccinated
or you've heard about
herd immunity which means if you get
enough
people who are either infected and
protected
or vaccinated and protected you have
kind of a shield over the community
but that's got to be a substantial
proportion
of the of the population that's
vaccinated in addition
it also depends on the efficacy level of
the vaccine
because if you have a vaccine that's
only 70
so percent effective you've got to have
even more of the population vaccinated
so you need a highly effective vaccine
and the overwhelming majority of the
population being vaccinated and is that
a percentage we can expect
sort of 70 to 75 percent effectiveness
you know i hope so uh the trials are
geared
two of them to detect a 60
efficacy with a degree of certainty
and one what i think is a 50 percent the
ones that are out in front right now are
looking at a
60 i would hope that we could get a 70
plus
percent effective vaccine because if we
then
vaccinate widely and combine
that with continuation of certain of the
public health measures you don't
necessarily
need to be astringent but some of them
like mask wearing and avoiding
crowds without a mask which is a
surefire invitation
to a problem and what would you say is
the most important thing that we know
now
that we didn't necessarily know say in
march or when
when lockdown started you know i think
it's exactly what you said
a there were there were a few things we
didn't know we didn't know
what percentage of people were
asymptomatic
carriers of the virus we didn't know the
extent to which they could spread
and we didn't know the full spectrum
of disease it was either well either you
go to the hospital you die or you get
better and you're fine
we know now that there are some people
maybe a significant number who have
lingering symptoms that go on for weeks
if not months and maybe
longer we know that children can have a
very unusual
hyperinflammatory syndrome which is
very similar to a strange disease called
kawasaki disease
where they get skin rashes and mucosal
rashes they often go to an icu
they often have to be hospitalized
that's something that we need to take
seriously
and would you say it's quite a weird
question not to put a positive spin on
the pandemic but is this quite an
interesting one from your medical point
of view well it's interesting and
perplexing
you know one of the things that people
have asked me i've been
involved in as i say chasing pandemic
outbreaks for now over 36
years ever since the very early days of
the
hiv aids pandemic and
when people ask me what's your
worst case scenario what's your worst
nightmare
i would always say it would be a new
infection that jumps species from an
animal reservoir and has two
characteristics one
that it spreads very very efficiently
from human to human
and two it has a substantial degree of
morbidity and mortality
either for the general population or for
a certain subgroup of individuals
and we've had examples of outbreaks
that have had one or the other of those
characteristics but not both of them
together
right you know and when you have both of
them together
then you have a historic
outbreak the likes of which we have not
seen in 102 years
since the 1918 famous or infamous
spanish flu so this is something
that as you know involves over 215
countries
we now have you know a considerable tens
of millions of infections
worldwide with close to a million deaths
in this our own country
we have more than six million infections
and now very close
if not already at 200 000 deaths
this is quite serious i actually watched
the documentary about the 80s
about a year ago and uh you feature
heavily in the hiv episode so
i felt in very good hands when you're on
the news for covert
okay i do have one final question what
has been
personally for you the most frustrating
thing about this pandemic you know what
the most frustrating thing for me
is is the lack of a of a uniform
response
among the states you know one of the
great things about our country is we
have federalism in the states have the
power
to do what they want to do the only
difficulty with that
is that often you have different
viewpoints and
different issues that come up and states
may do something different the other
frustrating
issue is the lack of appreciation on the
part of
young people who for the most part do
very well with this with some exceptions
i mean compared to the elderly
and those with chronic conditions is
their lack of appreciation
that by getting infected and not caring
if they get infected like people you see
at bars crowded
no masks that they are actually
propagating the outbreaks so they are
part of the continuation of something
that we're trying to stop and although
they innocently and inadvertently
get infected and think they're in a
vacuum that they're not going to be
harming anyone else what happens is that
they may be without symptoms but they'll
transmit the infection
to someone else who might transmit it to
someone who is vulnerable
that could be someone's father or
grandfather
or wife who's on chemotherapy for a
breast cancer or a child who's
immunodeficient
so i'm frustrated by the lack of
appreciation that we are
all in this together and we're going to
end it
by ending it together not having some
people pay attention
to what they should be doing and other
people not yeah absolutely
it makes it extra frustrating for those
of us who have hardly been out
and you know wear masks all the time
when we do go out when you just see
people in the media doing
absolutely nothing at all it makes it
makes everything that we've been doing
seem a bit pointless
well not pointless for yourself but
pointless for the outbreak if in other
words it's pointless to get control of
the outbreak
you make a very good point well dr
fatchi thank you very much for being
in this slow-mo guys video and thank you
for
everything you've done for humans on
this planet
well thank you i appreciate you having
me on your program thank you
thank you nice to meet you well there we
have it using a light
and a high speed camera i feel like
we've sufficiently visualized
the microscopic lighter than air
particles that just
leak out of your face when you're having
a chat
it's it's scary stuff make sure you wear
a mask when you're out in public
big thanks to dr fauci for agreeing to
talk to me in this video
and even bigger thanks to you for
watching it make sure you check out the
other videos on the channel
they're not all as serious as this one
and please subscribe
if you like what you've seen i'll see
you in the next one